واحدة من أكثر
قصص الأسبوع روعة والتي لا يمكن تفسيرها بطريقة ما
تتضمن هذه الصور المذهلة
التي تم التقاطها بواسطة تلسكوب جيمس ويب
الفضائي ، قيل لنا أن هذه الصور تظهر
نجومًا مشكلة حديثًا ومنطقة تسمى
أعمدة الخلق ، فهذه الصور
مذهلة ولكن إذا كنت ''
إذا كنت مثلي ، ليس لديك أي فكرة عما ننظر
إليه هنا ، لذا دعنا نجلب مايك مينزل
مهندس أنظمة مهام ناسا
لتلسكوب جيمس ويب ليخبرنا ما
هذا مايك شكرًا جزيلاً لكونك
هنا موضع ترحيب ، لذا دعنا أولاً وقبل كل شيء  أقول
إننا علمنا أن أعمدة الخلق
كانت موجودة لأن تلسكوب هابل
قد التقط هذه الصور منذ حوالي 30 عامًا ،
ومن الواضح أنه صورة أوضح بكثير
اليوم ما هذا الذي
أنظر إليه هنا ، هذه سحابة ضخمة من
الغاز في الفضاء تدور حولها  على بعد 6500
سنة ضوئية منا ، ربما يبلغ حجم السحابة نفسها
حوالي 10 سنوات ضوئية
وما تراه هو منطقة
تولد فيها كميات هائلة من النجوم
خارج المجال.  إذا كان هناك
نجوم ولدت بالفعل
نجومًا حارة جدًا وهي في الواقع تقوم الآن
بتبخير السحابة التي
ولدت فيها ، وبالتالي فإن التبخر
يقشر طبقات الغاز
ويترك الطبقات الأكثر كثافة هناك
وتلك الطبقات الكثيفة هي ما أنت عليه  انظر
هناك باسم أعمدة الخلق الآن
وقد أطلق عليها لقب ذلك لأنه داخل
هذه الأعمدة لا تزال النجوم
تولد وهذه الصورة الأخيرة من
تلسكوب جيمس ويب الفضائي تحتوي على بعض
الأشياء الرائعة جدًا في المناطق الحمراء
التي وصفها علماء الفلك
بأنها تبدو وكأنها تبحث  مثل الحمم البركانية هي في
الواقع نجوم جديدة
ولدت للتو وهي تقذف
غازًا في ما نسميه جيتس وهذا
ما ترونه هنا لم
تره على صورة هابل ، نعم لأن
الأطوال الموجية للأشعة تحت الحمراء التي قام جيمس
نظر ويبر لم يكتشفه
أه بواسطة تلسكوب هابل الفضائي